the working story for this project was
water slavers really I just went out to
look for pictures of women carrying
water I mean it was that simple
specifically we went to Ethiopia
Tanzania and Kenya every woman I met was
a beast of burden and she knew it
how many women said to me this is my
life we are powerless to change you know
they get up in the morning to a claw put
the empty jerry cans on their back grab
their kids and start a five hour walk to
the water source well I wouldn't call it
a well it was sort of like a muddy
indentation in the sand and in that
indentation the water sort of seeps up
when you gather water like this it takes
hours to fill a jerrican and this tank
McKenna serves about eight hundred
families so this is in the early morning
as the water is beginning to run out
women are literally begging for the
water now fill my bucket fill mine
because they know it would be two weeks
before another drop came their way look
at those women and understand the
struggle that they have to deal with
every day
to get a cup of water not even clean
water it's muddy water it's contaminated
one what choice do they have
we can look at it here we can look at
the people who are suffering and not
turn away then perhaps you can start to
change things so it's a fundamental
requirement of moving to hope of moving
to joy moving to progress